good to see you Daniel Jeremiah what's
up button how you doing ma'am how are
you doing I'll tell you what it's just
trying to build the energy for this for
this draft and to walk in just a minute
ago and and to hear you guys talk about
the Stanford punter I just I felt the
jiggly energy in the crowd well he's
just taking off he's moving up trap
words there you go but the reason why I
asked you how you're doing is did you
ever see the movie the sting you ever
see this thing in film class in college
in all right there's a there's a scene
in the sting where it's the day of the
big sting and Paul Newman is in the spot
where they're gonna have the sting and
the guy that he is hired to protect the
Robert Redford character walks in and he
thinks that the guy who's there to
protect the Robert Redford character is
gonna tell him some bad news
yeah and then Robert Redford walks in
the door any exhales that's the way I
felt about mike Mayock every single you
do in a dress so now I ask you you
feeling good you're good I can exhale
there you go well it's good to see you
man it's gonna seem excited to have you
in that spot I mean you've done it for
so many years and then tonight the first
few minutes of the draft I mean last
year when we were sitting there and
Dallas together it was gonna be is it
darn old is it Mayfield could it
possibly be say Quon Berkeley nobody
really thought that was entirely
possible but Mayfield or Donald tonight
it's totally wide-open after months of
it being Mari Murray Murray are you
hearing what are you hearing right now
at you Jay I try to divorce myself from
whatever you hear in the last 48 hours
of the process and go with look at all
smoke and mirrors a lot of that stuff
but look there's it's not done if it's
not done and Josh Rosen has not been
traded then there's intrigue in mystery
I still feel like Cuyler Murray will be
the pick because it's all pointed in
that direction and I think it's a
peculiar handling of Josh Rosen if they
aren't gonna take Cuyler murid right but
it's not done so there's still that
potential it could be Quinn and Williams
it could be Bosa and then even after
that and the 49ers have talked about
potentially trading out everybody in the
Jets have called they probably called a
couple people in here
anybody received a call from the Jets
here inside the Marriott yes this
gentleman in the Colts Hat says that but
I don't believe one way to go it's smoke
and mirrors that was a smoke and nurse
thing right here brother this gentleman
from the AFC South so I'm also hearing
that the Cardinals have not had a
conversation about trading Josh Rosen
with somebody in a very long time also
so unless Steve crime struck a deal with
somebody three weeks ago and it's in his
right or left hand drawer that he's
gonna be able to pull out the minute
they hand in the Murray name tonight
yeah hard to be totally mystified you
know how hard it is to keep a secret in
the NFL yeah so if you already had a
deal worked out you've got to have
silence on the Arizona side which can be
difficult but even more difficult would
be silence on the team that's gonna
acquire him right that gets out if
that's done I would think that would
have leaked out but I've heard nothing
but they have to trade rosin
hand-in-hand of doing it right I mean
you've got a you've got to extract the
draft picks now for tonight because the
minute that they draft board come in the
minute the draft closes tonight or even
gets passed through 15 you can't trade
rosin for you trade them for pennies on
the dollar everything no you have to get
rid of him it's musical chairs and the
seats are gonna fill up tonight so your
leverage is going out the window now I
do I kind of laugh because they've got
it out there in a big way we're not
gonna give away Josh Rosen we're gonna
keep him that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna go forward with him and
Kyler Murray in the same room that's
gonna be a great way for Kyler Murray to
enter into the NFL there is no chance
that's to me is their way of trying to
generate leverage where they might not
have that well yesterday when we had
Steve Mariucci on when I asked him is it
at all possible yeah that Rosen and
Murray could be I can't tell you that he
called that gasoline and matches with
the rewards he called it and he says
that's gasoline and matches it's hard
enough when you have a veteran at the
end of the line and you bring in the
young guy now you've got a second-year
player with somebody coming up with the
number one pick in the draft there's no
way that can't we'll see and then you
know for me we're gonna play this on our
pre-show on the NFL Network tonight our
pre draft show Mayock last year when
McGann we're all sitting there me you
and him and David Shaw and Dallas
and the Browns are put on the clock and
Mayock I said well what do you think and
he goes well you're John Dorsey you're a
new general manager and the ant-like a
soliloquy about thirty Seconds know
about how this is an important pic to
let the building know who you are as a
general manager and who you view is the
prototypical fill in the blank of the
player of the team that you're on yeah
so tonight obviously the dorsey
relationship with you jackson is totally
different from the front of Mayock and
Gruden sure but tonight you know hearing
the name of say Devon white yeah right a
thumper from right in the middle of the
defense or some pass rusher who's got a
nasty streak in him that strikes me of
what not only the Raiders need but
Phil's what Mayock has already
verbalized what in his mind a general
manager needs to do with his first pick
I wonder what you think well I talked to
him yesterday and I start spitting back
the words from his press conferences
he's like oh you you picked that up I
said yeah I'm studying Mike I'm gonna
listen to what you said in the first
press conference he used the phrase
foundational players this is kind of a
culture building draft for them much
like he talked about last year with John
Dorsey it's and I described as a middle
of the fairway draft this is not a
driver draft this is just get good solid
players I parked that thing in the
fairway and and and these are gonna be
core members of your team going forward
they have multiple picks next year too
so that there might be different players
they can get a little bit sexier but for
this first one to me it's right in the
middle of the fairway and I could see
even you know people say who could be an
out of left field pick at number four in
Haskins I think is possible I think
that's very much in play but even
somebody like Devin Bush where people
would say map it's a little bit high but
that is in the dead middle of the
fairway yes what'd you get well look if
if Mayock after us hanging out for 15
years in the draft and the amount of
grief that he would give me anytime a
Wolverine was either selected for him to
go over for him to go Wolverine as his
first pick as a general manager making
him a top five which I don't know I
can't remember I think Jake Long was
last Michigan player that was a top five
player in the draft right you're nodding
your head Brockman correct I believe
so if Mayock makes that stat mm-hmm I
will blow his phone hub like he would
just be just stop texting me he might
actually erase me or block me from his
phone
what will happen so because tonight he
could go Michigan man in the in the
first round he Oh Jalen more appstate
running back in the fourth and for
Charles there are no Tennessee players
in a draft you got to be careful in this
time your go-to thing is to rag on get
some count here on this strand that's
what I think too is you know Cris
Collinsworth tweeted out today that his
hot take did you see this from
Collinsworth on Twitter today his hot
take for the draft his hot flat-out
prediction for the draft is that Roger
Goodell is gonna get a standing ovation
because things are different in the
south is what he said let me tell you
what's not happening Roger Goodell
giving a shirred tonight I don't know I
mean I asked the people there's
Tennessee people were shaking ball
there's a Dallas guy who's shaking his
head no right now sir what he did with
Ezekiel Elliott just put that aside just
don't worry about that okay so what do
you think
tonight is going to bring we'll be
talking about what like when will you
and I are done tonight with David Shaw
and again our third our guest Kurt
Warner what do you think we will be
discussing after our broadcast tonight
Daniel I think we're gonna look at the
intrigue inside the NFC West this was a
doormat division for a while and now
when you look at it Seattle's got two
picks
so pressure on them to find somebody to
fill the role with Frank Clark leaving
they've got two first rounders you look
at the top of the draft they go one and
two yes
so not only that's to me the interesting
discussion about Kyle Emery you not only
take Kyler Murray one quarterbacks
back-to-back years my opinion you gift
wrap the best defensive player in the
draft to a team inside your division
who's gonna be playing against Kyler
very interesting so you've got that
intrigue in that connection there inside
that division and then you've got the
team that was in the Super Bowl fending
NFC picking at the bottom of the first
round who's got a little bit of age in
the offensive line and they want to take
one there do they try and trade back I
just I think it's a fascinating division
what was that number I asked you who
during our combine coverage 21 you say
there would be 21 defense you I asked
you it that during our combat coverage
how many defensive players are gonna be
chosen in the first round of the draft
because they were just jumping out of
the gym and running like
speed burners at ridiculous weights you
said 21 do you feel like that'll be now
that would be I think the records
nineteen so that would be big time news
about this hat but now here we are on
the track yeah so when you start getting
to it I here's the the thing that would
challenge that I think you make a case
21 at the top 32 players in the draft or
defensive players right we have so many
young quarterbacks in the NFL right now
with average to below average offensive
lines which is going to elevate those
linemen up and we could see a little bit
of a run on the offensive line those
guys maybe even going where they're
evaluated because look if you've got to
Shaun Watson and you're sitting there in
the 20s and and the top tackles are gone
which I think will take place you almost
have to reach for an offensive lineman
he cannot get hit like that another year
you have to invest in the office I mean
they have to the Texans have to go down
your corner like they say they need
corners I'm like that's great you have
to protect the Shaun Watson number one
that's it but I got to tell you it's
funny but it's it's almost like an AFC
South ritual it was the Colts for so
many years and now the Texans where
we're sitting on a draft set saying
they've got it taken off their lawmen
they have to take an offensive on and
then they don't well on until the Colts
finally did last year with this future
hall-of-famer from their game thank you
I mean he's nasty so um and then but you
have to see you have to understand the
importance of of what it is I mean
Andrew Luck was like Santiago from a few
good men who is not to be touched you
know he was order and he was hardly
touched last year so that's and it
starts with stuff that you see tonight I
hadn't packed the thing that he had in
fact a single thing there's no way
Mayock gets that by the way that's zero
by the way that's another reason why I'm
excited for you tonight like it was
either stripes or the Sugar Hill Gang or
nothing else you didn't understand
anything else usual references pop
culture we're gonna do it you lieutenant
Weinberg by the way did you see my
Instagram post today no I haven't seen
it okay I'll show it to you right here
it is the minute the second we went off
the air me you charles and mike Mayock
after Mike said he was a Beaver's guy
and we threw the look that's rid of the
Bears pick and they chose Deon Bush
that's you wiping your eyes with a
because you are crying and Mayock was
crying about we were laughing so hard we
think we had to throw to break
I might just let's get us at the
commercial break look let me night fun
is the energy and it's great but we're
gonna have a blast on day three yeah
that's when Peter Schrager joins me you
and Charles on the Tootsie set and
brought on Broadway I mean the setting
here is just truly unbelievable that's a
great city it really is and we're
excited not only to be here in the
courtyard with you and David Shaw
earlier on Kurt Warner's joining us
later on out if you saw Tim McGraw
retweeted our bromo that he's going to
be here at the downtown Nashville
courtyard about that so Tim McGraw is
making his way here we're gonna talk
Friday Night Lights with him correct too
and especially since he just tweeted out
at a photograph talking on hey welcome
to draft day here in Nashville it looks
like ham is a high school football
player look an old picture you get take
a look at it Wow yeah it's really
interesting ask him something for me off
the air real quick because I went to
Northeast Louisiana before I transferred
to AB state and I think Tim McGraw went
to Northeast Louisiana I will definitely
do that write that down for me Chris
alright so we're here our number one is
in the books from the Courtyard by
Marriott Downtown in Nashville please
join us here if you're here in person
because Tim McGraw is coming up our two
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app